i don't know just be a good person what
about that just be nice to people you
know
yeah like a lot of it doesn't add up i
can't keep track of all the rules
like transgender what do you think
that's how i feel i don't give a [ __ ]
you want to go for a man a woman go nuts
well go labia
what's the beef look it's weird to hate
someone because they're trans right but
it's also weird to love someone because
they're trans
shouldn't you like them based on who
they are as a person content to the
character people are so phony i love
caitlyn jenner why
she sucks
she's against gay marriage and ran over
a person what's the good part
and they go well they have hard lives
all right well so do bidgets
why don't you talk about how much you
like them where's that hashtag i don't
see any tweets about midgets
who's got a heart at a minute hard to
get around hard to drive hard to get
work no love and look i'm not anti-trans
but i am pro-midge
i just don't get why we help one group
but not another it's just kind of trendy
and people say well trans aren't allowed
everywhere well you're being a roller
coaster
[Music]
at least trans we accommodate with the
bathrooms midgets ever seen how tall a
toilet is
imagine having a jump to take a dump
weird no help no support
and you know what's great about midgets
i got a couple [ __ ] friends they're
good eggs
you never see a [ __ ] complaining never
every other group complains
never a [ __ ] never see it on the news
sitting at a desk legs dangling little
fish
never every other group complains i see
women on news we have a glass ceiling
midget's like you're worried about the
ceiling
holy [ __ ] i'm trying to [ __ ] with this
counter baby
interesting see i guess i'm too
open-minded because i support all
transition not just sexual why do we
stop at sexual i support transition to
personality transition of uh
opinion right like kevin hart kevin hart
got in trouble with some offensive
tweets from years ago
i'm not the same guy i was from years
ago i've transitioned i used to have sex
with 16 year olds
when i was 16. now i don't i'm different
well years ago he said some offensive
stuff well years ago she won the men's
relay people
change why do you support that and not
that
huh it just tells me if i ever get into
trouble now i'm just gonna get a sex
change because you gotta kiss my ass
hey mark we heard that interview from
ten years ago that was mark
i'm margaret
i don't know i support kevin hart also
because he's a [ __ ]
oh there we go